économie environnement énergie au social
et
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant
aujourd'hui nous allons vous présenter
des éco gestes pour éviter de gaspiller
l'électricité dans la classe venait je
vais vous le montrer
est ce qu'on a vraiment des hommes la
lumière aujourd'hui il fait grand soleil
et
que ge est un on tire les rideaux au
lieu d'allumer les lumières
et que ge est deux on étend les
ordinateurs quand on a terminé de
travailler
éco-gestes 3 on est allé ventilateur ou
la clim quand on quitte la classe
comme le montre ce drapeau qui flotte à
l'entrée du collège depuis juin 2009 le
collège jean des sme est labellisé éco
école au collège saint des saints nous
incitons chacun à adopter des éco gestes
pour qu'il y ait plus de solidarité
entre nous pour améliorer notre cadre de
vie et pour respecter l'environnement
je peux économiser jusqu'à 140 euros sur
mes factures edf
comment j'utilise de préférence et
brasseurs d'air si je mets la
climatisation que la règle à 25 degrés
et pas plus bas je referme rapidement la
porte de mon réfrigérateur j'utilise des
ampoules basse consommation je choisis
des appareils ménagers étiqueté à plus
qu'ils sont plus économes je place le
congélateur dans un endroit tempéré
j'opte pour un chauffe eau solaire alors
vous voyez préserver l'environnement
c'est augmenter notre pouvoir d'achat le
conseil général agit
le monde durable les vous
économie environnement énergie au social
m
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant